do you recommend film school for every
aspiring filmmaker what if someone can't
afford it or unable to get a scholarship
no not necessarily I think it's I think
it's a way to get your films made
inexpensively and to be in an
environment and with students who are
like-minded in in certain ways who have
who share with you you know your time in
the universe and it can be very helpful
to you because they they have a
perspective on what you're trying to do
as an artist that actually no one else
has because of that so even the even the
professor's or even you know filmmakers
who are well established or famous who
come to talk to the students they're
still talking from a slightly different
place or even a tremendously different
place than the peer group so I think
there's a great deal that can be gotten
from that and you know in a short fairly
short amount of time and also the
different film schools that's have
different ways of specializing and how
they teach film so one of the strengths
of NYU which is clearly the one I know
the best is that everyone works on
everybody else's film everybody makes
films and it means at the end of that
period of time you know so much about
production that I think when you get out
in the real world
nobody can pull the wool over your eyes
as to what's going on in production and
the same advice that you gave to those
students in terms of keeping a database
of everyone in the class do you
recommend that to people that are fresh
off the bus to Los Angeles as well oh
absolutely you just never know when you
know somebody will become important I
mean look at the Chinese American girl
who happen to have a background in
medicine or in science who then went to
do this documentary in China which was a
kind of extraordinary putting together
of two people who had a common interest
they wouldn't have known about if I
didn't have the database
you